les filles il faut que je vous parle
papa est parti vous êtes disputer non il
va revenir nepad et iso et rabat est
parti avec la poule du soin de coiffure
il reviendra pas point barre
mais qu'est ce que je t'ai fait tu m'as
fait que mon père s'est cassé parce que
tu es moche et shirt en même temps tu me
diras bon débarras j'ai jamais compris
comment il faisait bon je supporte sera
témoin ça fait longtemps qu'ils soient
restitués laporte penses quoi
machete pas imagine pas de match on se
retrouve tout seul trouvent du travail
comment et où tu arrêtes tes sur itunes
incapable mais j'ai un travail je te
rappelle que je suis chercheuse au cnrs
et toi iris raconte qu est ce que tu as
fait de passionnant cette semaine j'ai
commencé à écrire tu écris nous savoir
sur quoi
si l'histoire d'une femme marchande au
12e siècle sur tous les sujets possibles
et imaginables la politique juste l'état
soir
mais alors qu'est ce que j'ai appris il
paraît que c'est écrit un roman ton
histoire de femmes marchande royal agen
mais c'est minable tu m'a toujours dit
que c'était ringard le moyen âge j'ai
besoin d'écrire gens crèvent dans vie
oui j'y arrive pas j'en suis incapable
et alors et alors tu vas écrire ce livre
tu sais si c'est nul 1-1 c'est elle qui
va tous prendrait pas moi et 6 épargnés
de sa marge
comment vivez vous votre succès mais le
succès je le vis bien guerre bien bien
si ça permet moi car de quoi exactement
où ton la décence
tout ça pour quoi pour alice n'a même
pas écrit je comprends pas il n'a pas
changé d'avis ce bouquin si justement
été complètement à côté de la plaque ma
peau filles avec ta générosité à la con
de quoi tu as peur exactement je suis
pas du tout tu perds ta vie à fuir envie
de vivre ta pour proville